fifth kumitachi
this is the regular style
all right
hey
the idea is always to take the ken
that's the only purpose of the fifth
generation
i don't know why census says that and
then you go on to do a lot more
that's what he would say
hey
he's coming to cut that back leg
but about halfway through
i see what he's gonna do so i actually
reverse it and he sees me reverse it so
he goes up i need to move out the way it
then comes here
let me finish
why i like this one is it's not on a
straight line it's not static
you can end up anywhere
[Music]
but over the years i've found lots of
errors in it
i found that if he's stronger than me so
someone i'm a small person or i'm a low
grade
i come here and about here he powered me
and the wrong person's won so i go no i
have to win this one i just don't mind
or what happens is i go oh i must be the
attacker
what's up the tackle wasn't so your
whole kim attack is messed up in your
head because you're you're doing all
these moves thinking some of you might
know what i mean thinking
did we switch over you don't wait until
you get to the end and go
i think we switched over
so
the difference is someone on my level
even higher cytoscency
he's got so much power in his body
it doesn't matter when you do this
it's
it's mass
so
nobody's thinking who's the winner we
can see it so
we don't change over
so what i've done is psycho essentially
when i got my fifth and asked me to
develop ken and joe
so
i told him i'd got no chance and he said
i would have because in my head i would
see a red light
basically he said you'll know it's wrong
tony i i know you well enough after 20
years i know you'll know
so what i done was
i do it this way
i push him out well out so he knows
who's the winner of this
but nigel was quite good because we're
such good friends he said
that's not silo senses first kimitatsu
scentsy but actually that's nobody's
going to actually i don't really like
that one too much so i've gone halfway
i thought oh yeah
first time he's ever actually said that
to me
so i said to him well you must be doing
something different than me
i said to him what i'm doing is i'm
doing a women heaven
what do you think i'm doing he said i
think you're overpowering me
and sort of coming in his face on here
on here
so he thought i was overpowering him and
i said no i'm actually going past you
but
but he'll sit out his eye
so we go here and i come really close
but here
you know because i'm now the one cutting
first
he has to back off
then it goes back to his standard
standard
so each time we can see who's got to
lose
there's no question
but this comes with rank rather than
bullying
right
hey
okay do your best it's complicated
we'll do it slowly
i covered my head you see all these
principles
have to be worked out the same a lot of
people will go like that you say i'm at
half way how often i my head could get
here i can see so i think so my brain is
telling me i'm oh i'm okay because i can
tell you but you don't realize this fits
out the top so you do have to
go over and over basics of basic
thoughts of what what is safety
here he's he's gonna
he went to a big step but he sees that
we're in the middle so he he does a
small step
so when i said to you earlier about
don't do that keep it on the chest on
the second
kim attaching
what ah
here it is again you see
can you bought from the second kim
attaching out to the fifth
if you do if you were making hours then
you make whatever's there and you'll
make them here
and that jump then becomes
a rabbit jump a bunny hop
hey
when you feel like that yes then you
know you got it right okay let's try
yin and yang again
you can guess what side you are doing
i'm going to tell you about each piece
i'm going to be the attacker i do a
straight cut
but i all of a sudden realize he's
vanished so this is going to do a happo
geary footwork it's going to come round
here
and then i'm going to push off that leg
to get there
all right
but watch nigel's ken
[Music]
and who's supposed to be the winner
really
i'm sorry
and that's why i've converted this
because it shouldn't
come into question
so what i do is when it's in movement
slowly
i go oh
and i push off that front leg
now he's winning or unleashing
i see this side so i get a chance to win
he comes in but as he comes in i see his
back leg
so i start going here
but he's gone out the circle so actually
he won't win
and i win again
so
really the fifth can attach you is a bit
like saying
but you've got all your wetting scrolls
and now you're going to get the master's
degree it's the fifth room attaches
basically when you've got all the others
in the bag it's so complicated
oh i won
and it will happen over and over
until nigel works out that he's actually
got to
we'll tell you the technical side he's
overpower me with his you know bulliness
or whatever so when i come here he's
gotta be look
he's gotta feel like that
i've got no question about i've gotta
get out of the way
when it comes to this he comes in
he's got to
just bring his foot up here
stay where he is and he just i was on
the spot
because he took the center ground
we're going to swap over so i could just
show you
no questions
remember this from this morning
first came attaching keep going
so a bit from the first contact you know
it's all piecing together
ice cream attaching
all right so that's why i say it's like
the masters level in my opinion because
without you knowing it you've got all
pieces from
kimitati's
so if you can't get this one
good
because you shouldn't be getting it yet
all right
[Music]
what